[Music]
so female mandrels they do actually like
meals with nice big colorful bumps the
male's they are so handsome
they have both pink purple blue and red
and it shines so brightly that you have
no doubt where he is when he walks in in
the forest far away from you
like other monkeys and if they live in a
hierarchy so if you look into a troop of
mandrels there will always be one
mandrels more colorful than all the
other males and there will be the high
ranking male and the lower ranking male
they will also have palace but they will
be less fleshy actually the male's they
actually fight for the middle in the
little monkey society so when a lower
ranking mandrill is fighting his way up
through the rank when they win the crown
if you can say that his testosterone
will actually rise and the colourful
face and bum will actually come by
itself so the high level of testosterone
actually leads them to lose hair on
their bum so the bright skin is
displayed even more the advantages of
being big and colorful is that you get
the right to mate with the females
[Music]
it does show which mail will give her
the good kids so it's the ability to
actually color increase or color enhance
that tells all the females that while
your ladies come come to me because I
can give you your good offspring the pie
ah
that's nice mr. ping behind some job
[Music]